>> Laura: TALK ABOUT A
DOUBLE STANDARD.
GET.
THIS THE "BOSTON
THIS THE BBOSTON
THIS THE BOSTON WON A
PLULTER IS FOR REPORTING ON
DOMESTIC ABUSE.
NOW THEY ARE FACING THEIR
PERSONNEL MATTER.
THIS FROM THE PAPER THAT
ARGUED THE PUBLIC INTEREST
OUTWEIGHED THE PRIVACY OF
PRIESTS IN SEEKING UNUNSEAL
EVIDENCE.
HIGH POP IS I?
HYPOCRISY?
AND CATHY AREU PUBLISHER OF
CATALINA MAGAZINE.
GREAT TO SEE BOTH OF YOU.
THANKS FOR JOINING US.
THANKS FOR TOUCHING IT OUT
WITH US.
I LOVE IT YOU CAN'T KEEP A
BILL, THE "BOSTON GLOBE"
SAYS THIS IS A DIFFERENT
SITUATION.
THIS WAS NOT A CASE OF THIS
INDIVIDUAL EMPLOYEE
COMMITTING ANY ACTS OF
PHYSICAL VIOLENCE.
THEY SITE THAT AS THE REASON
THEY NEED TO READ
MASSACHUSETTS LAW.
MASSACHUSETTS LAW DEFINES
SEXUAL HARASSMENT AS VERBAL
AS WELL AS PHYSICAL CONDUCT
AND BEYOND THAT, THERE WERE
MANY, MANY PRIESTS WHO WERE
CHARGED WITH RATHER
SCREENIAL TYPE OF OFFENSES.
THAT DIDN'T MATTER AT ALL TO
THE "BOSTON GLOBE."
BETWEEN SOMEBODY WHO GRABS
SOMEBODY AND RAPE.
I HAVE MADE THAT DISCUSS
RANK HYPOCRITES AND ALL OF A
SUDDEN THEY DISCOVERED
PRIVACY RIGHTS AND
CONFIDENTIALITY.
ONE STANDARD FOR THE GLOBE
>> Laura: CATHY?
>> YEAH, BUT I MEAN TWO
WRONGS DON'T MAKE A RIGHT.
THE CHURCH NEEDS TO TAKE
CARE OF ITS PROBLEMS AND THE
"BOSTON GLOBE" NEEDS TO TAKE
CARE OF ITS PROBLEMS AND
SEXUAL ABUSE AND HARASSMENT
IS NOT OKAY ANYWHERE.
SO THE BOSTON GLOBAL DOESN'T
NEED TO REVEAL WHO IT
ACCUSED THE ALLEGED
HARASSERS ARE AS MUCH AS THE
CHURCH DOESN'T NEED TO DO
THAT.  THE LAW WILL DO THAT
IF THESE PEOPLE ARE GUILTY,
THEY WILL BE PUNISHED.
THAT'S WHAT WE SAW WITH THE
PRIEST WHO COMMITTED THE
CRIMES AND THAT'S WHAT WE'LL
SEE WITH THE "BOSTON GLOBE."
NOT A DOUBLE STANDARD AT
ALL.
FILED THIS COMPLAINT BACK IN
MARCH SAID HE PROPOSITIONED
HER TO HAVE SEXUAL REGIONS
WITH HIS WIFE.
VULGAR SEXUAL LANGUAGE
ACCORDING.
THE REPORTER RESIGNED.
>> OKAY.
>> THEY DECLINED TO IDENTIFY
THE EMPLOYEE HIS ALLEGED
CONDUCT DID NOT INVOLVE
YOU DESCRIBE PERSISTENT?
ONE ALLEGATION?
MANY ALLEGATIONS?
MAYBE NOT WITH THAT ONE
THIS TYPE OF CONDUCT IN THE
NEWSROOM SEEMS LIKE WHOSE OX
IS GORED HERE.
THEY CHAMPION THIS IDEA OF
FULL TRANSPARENCY BACK IN
2003 OR 2002.
>> RIGHT, WELL, BACK THEN
THEY DID IT BECAUSE THERE
WAS A DEFINITE PROBLEM GOING
ON WITH THE CATHOLIC CHURCH
AND THEY WERE REVEALING THE
PROBLEM AS A MEDIA SOURCE
SHOULD DO AS THE MEDIA
SHOULD DO.
THAT'S WHAT THE MEDIA DOES.
THEY ARE THE WATCHDOG OF THE
NOT GOING TO DESTROY A
PERSON'S REPUTATION AND LIFE
BASED ON ACCUSATION.
>> Laura: I THIS THINK ALL
THE MEN ACCUSED OF SEXUAL
HARASSMENT IN ALL THESE
>> THE LAW DOESN'T REQUIRE
GUILTY.
>> Laura: IT'S NOT A COURT
OF LAW.
GIVE YOU EXAMPLE HOW PHONY
THESE PEOPLE ARE NOT JUST AT
THE "BOSTON GLOBE."
>> A NUMBER OF YEARS AGO A
WOMAN CAME TO MY OFFICE AND
THE ACCUSED.
NOT ANYBODY WHO WAS FOUND
ANYBODY WHO HAS BEEN ACCUSED
THEY SHOULD PUT THAT UP ON
THE WEBSITE OF THE
ARCHDIOCESE.
SAID CAN I HAVE THE NAME OF
YOUR BOSS AND HIS PHONE
I SAID I'M GOING TO REPORT
YOU AS SEXUALLY ABUSING ME
AND THEN ASK WHETHER OR NOT
THEY WILL PUT YOUR NAME UP
ON THE WEBSITE OF CNN.
SHE SAID I GOT YOUR POINT
AND I PUT THE PHONE DOWN.
THIS JUST GREATS ME SO MUCH.
IF YOU WANT TO GO BACK TO
THE 1920S, THAT'S WHAT THE
"BOSTON GLOBE" SAYS, WE GO
BACK TO THE 1920S, ABOUT
ACCUSED PRIESTS.
THE BOSTON GLOBE GOES BACK
TO THE 1870s.
THE CATHOLIC LEAGUE WILL
PLAY FOR A LEAVING LAWYERS
TO LOOK AT THE "BOSTON
GLOBE" TO SEE IF THERE IS
ANY MORE OF THIS KIND OF
THEY ROLLED OUT A COUPLE OF
EXPECTED TO BELIEVE THAT'S
IT AND THEY DON'T PAY ANY
PRICE FOR IT AND THE LAW
ENFORCEMENT ARE ARE NOT
PHONINESS IN MY LIFE OUTSIDE
OF HOLLYWOOD, PERHAPS.
>> Laura: THEY SAY THEY HAVE
HIRED A LOT MORE WOMEN, A
LOT MORE WOMEN MANAGERS.
>> RIGHT.
I'M SURE IT CAN BE PROVEN.
WHAT THEY WERE DOING WITH
THE CATHOLIC CHURCH.
THE MEDIA HAS TO ASK THE
TOUGH QUESTIONS.
>> Laura: THEY HAVE TO ASK
THE TOUGH QUESTIONS OF
THEMSELVES.
YOU ARE MAKING MY POINT.
I'M GLAD THEY EXPOSED WHAT
THEY DID.
ET.
AND CATHOLIC CHURCH SHOULD
TAKE CARE OF THEIR PROBLEMS.
>> PROBLEMS NOT GOING TO
INVESTIGATE THEM.
>> THEY HAVE BEEN
INVESTIGATED.
>> Laura: INVESTIGATE
THEMSELVES, YEAH.
WELL, WE WILL SEE.
WE WILL FIND OUT OTHER
CASES.